so Steve thank you for coming and we
look forward to showing you everything
we can today we feel very bullish about
Pittsburgh very bullish about carnival
and we think the Carnegie Mellon is the
number one most entrepreneurial research
university in the United States and we
we can't wait to show that off today I
realized something in the last year that
i did not know a year ago Carnegie
Mellon is among the top one or two
universities in the country by any
metric that has spun out more companies
per dollar of research money spent than
any other university in the country
that's literally bang for the buck that
combined with the fact that the city of
Pittsburgh has started to grow after
decades of decline and that population
now comprises fifty percent with college
degree and some something on the order
of thirty percent with a master's degree
it's a highly educated population bodes
well for the future because part of the
reason we're here is not to talk but to
listen and learn and our hope is that
we'll be able to learn enough that we
can help tell the story of Pittsburgh
and what's happening here and what's
happening at CMU in particular all
around the country indeed all around the
world and try to help do our part of of
taking this region to sort of the next
level I think it's worth kind of
reminding ourselves that 250 years ago
America was just a start-up it was just
an idea but the story around Pittsburgh
the story around you know Carnegie
Mellon is not as well understood around
the country around the world is it needs
to be I'm sure you see this here at the
at CMU it really is a magnet for talent
to come here to study ultimately it
comes down to great entrepreneurs with
great ideas
what do over 30 Tony Award winners have
in common with pioneers in engineering
and science what do iconic artists have
in common with thousands of innovative
entrepreneurs what do 19 Nobel Prize
winners driverless cars and founders of
artificial intelligence have to do with
Juicy Couture their ideas all started at
Carnegie Mellon University ideas that
shape your world start here